straight ahead on law and crime daily
college student molly tibbetts convicted
killer wants a new trial
the judge now considering the words of
one inmate against another
he says we set him up he did not kill
him the so-called killer clown cold case
trial
gets delayed when will we know who
really was under the mask
i don't think i've ever had a case that
is closer to a movie
and wealthy donor ed buck convicted in
the overdose deaths of two men in his
house
in a party and play scheme he the
monster has stolen this bright light
plus the family of samantha josephson in
tears her killer
fake uber driver nathaniel rowland
sentenced to life in prison
the defendant's mother clashing with the
judge he didn't do this
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a judge in iowa is now considering
whether the convicted killer of college
student molly tibbetts
should get a new trial a jury found
christian bahana rivera guilty of
first-degree murder of mollie tibbetts
in may he led investigators to her body
in her cornfield in august 2018
at trial he claimed other men killed her
and forced him to move her body
and now his attorneys are asking for a
new trial after an inmate is coming
forward claiming another inmate confess
that he stabbed tibis to death as part
of a sex trafficking attempt
gone wrong there
he heard a noise from the room he opened
the door he seen a woman ball into a
chair
and gagged and was able to identify that
woman
he later on he did he went upstairs
and said that
if the police went to the next house
over
they would have caught her and i said
who's that
tibbetts and that's when the sick
trafficker said that
that he had to get rid of her so he went
back down there and stabbed her to death
and then
put her in a turn
on cross-examination prosecutors pointed
out that the inmate who allegedly
confessed
was only 17 years old at the time he's
reportedly told the associated press
he had nothing to do with tibbetts death
and you stated in one of those
interviews that gavin jones told you
that he
and this other individual cut up molly's
body correct
yes are you aware
that the facts are the case and the
evidence
did not show that particular fact
uh i didn't know but that's that's what
he did tell me
but i didn't believe and you went to
prison in november of 2020 correct
left october 19th you went to prison on
october 19 2020 yes
and you didn't tell anyone about the
statements that
gavin jones supposedly made to you until
may 26th of this year correct
correct the defense then
asked the lead investigator if he ever
received tips during the death
investigation
that molly tibbetts was a victim of sex
trafficking
it's possible there was a i we had tips
that she was eating ice cream in sioux
falls and eating tacos in denver
colorado so
yeah it would not surprise me if there
were tips that she was a victim of sex
trafficking
wouldn't you agree sir that if you had
that information
in that month that molly tibbetts was
missing
that that would be relevant information
well i suppose it
would depend when i got that information
if i
got that information after christian
rivera confessed and took us to the body
and we were able to corroborate his
entire confession
then i probably would have disregarded
that
prosecutors were quick to point out all
the evidence used to convict the
defendant in the murder
that lead that was developed off of that
video
from logan collins residents
was essentially the lead that broke open
this case correct
that is true yes christian rivera was
tied to that chevy malibu
uh through a vehicle stop well not a
vehicle stop but an interaction that
steve kibby had with him
uh in august of 2018. correct that is
correct
that vehicle was found later to contain
the blood of mollie tibbetts correct
that is correct
and he ended up confessing to the death
or to the killing of molly tibbetts
correct yes he did
any connection at all through your
investigation
to gavin jones dustin hanson james lowe
or anyone else other than christian
rivera no christian rivera murdered
molly tibbetts
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney gigi gonzalez and terry austin
gigi what kind of and how much
information does the judge need
to grant a new trial you know it's not
so much volume it's just got to be
material enough
that if it's introduced to a jury it
could likely induce a different verdict
and here jailhouse informant with no
incentive other than to do what is right
is stepping forward and saying that
there is a different defendant and a
different set of circumstances
revolving uh around this case so it
could be very persuasive to a juror
if they did hear that now terry does the
fact of the defense argument
and this supposed confession slightly
differ work against the defense
well yes it will work against the
defense listen i think what the
prosecution is trying to say here
is that bahina rivera confessed to this
murder
all of the evidence points to that
original confession
and he's trying now to backtrack these
other
individuals who are saying that two
other men came and killed her
and asked rivera to hide the body that
is not connecting with the
evidence that the prosecution found so i
think that the jury might be
confused and i think that we could
potentially
ultimately hear all of this evidence but
i you know
really i think that that original
confession should stand
right we'll see how the judge decides
this the judge has said
that he would give a written ruling on
the issue and of course when he does
we'll be here to break it all down for
you
on law and crime daily thank you both
still ahead on law and crime daily a
jury's verdict for political donor ed
buck
on trial for trading drugs and sex
leading to the deaths of two men
but first when will we know who was the
real face under the clown mass
that shot a florida mother the latest in
the killer clown cold case
next
[Music]
welcome back a delay in a
long-anticipated killer clown trial in
florida
law and crime's angenette levy spoke
with the palm beach county prosecutor
about the case and the delay brian
sheila keen warren's murder trial was
expected to start
in september but the defense asked for a
delay
and they got it when will you be ready
to try this case judge i we are thinking
end of march beginning of april
and with that the trial of sheila keane
warren was delayed until march
2022 the florida woman is accused of
dressing up like a clown getting out of
a chrysler lebaron
and shooting and killing marlene warren
in may of 1990
in the doorway of her home marlene
warren was the wife of keane warren's
current husband
michael warren this is a cold case from
1990 so it's frustrating for
the victim's family and for us
prosecutors that it continues to be
delayed but
we respect the court's decision and
we'll be ready early next year
palm beach county state's attorney dave
ehrenberg initially sought the death
penalty against keen warren but later
took it off the table
she was indicted in 2017 for marlene
warren's murder
there are reasons why the defendant is
alleged to have
done this by dressing up as a clown i
can't get
into the evidence of the case because
it's a pending matter
but at trial there will be evidence as
to why
the defendant did what she did
ehrenberg says advances in dna and other
technology helped identify keane warren
as the killer clown but what about her
now husband
michael warren the husband has not been
charged with any crime relating to
this murder and that is something that
we do not have the evidence yet to file
charges against anyone else
at this point now the defense attorneys
said they wanted
to delay the trial because they said
they were still receiving discovery and
had other witnesses that they hoped to
depose in the case to help them prepare
for trial
that trial now scheduled to begin in
march of 2022
brian thanks ange back with us as
criminal defense attorney gigi gonzalez
and terry austin
terry the case is described as being
completely circumstantial
so what kind of evidence should we
expect in this trial
you know i think what most people don't
realize is that a lot of cases are tried
with circumstantial evidence that just
means that the jury or the fact finder
has to infer from the evidence versus
direct evidence which would be an
eyewitness or a video or confession
and you don't often have that so here it
does seem as though
it's going to be all circumstantial but
the prosecution is holding that close
to the vest so i think we will see this
dna evidence as
angenette reported or we might hear
something about the car that was used
during this
murder so i think they're going to put
all of that circumstantial evidence
together
and the jury will be able to make a
decision yeah i would tend to agree both
on how trials typically are and how this
may be proved
by the prosecution gigi the prosecution
has said there was a reason
keen warren wore a clown outfit but
hasn't said why any guesses as to why
i think she did it for the element of
surprise even though
clowns are kind of scary at least to me
they're kind of scary
but you might open the door to a clown
that's got balloons and flowers which
was the whole goal of the defendant here
was to get the door open so that she
could shoot
her in the face allegedly that's what
the state's gonna say that's my guess
that would show consciousness of guilt
as well as a plan to commit the murder
so that could
kind of check off the boxes here for the
prosecution and jeanette
why did the state's attorney take the
death penalty off the table
well you know brian dave ehrenberg said
they have dna evidence in this case and
they have
other evidence that came to them through
advances in technology and he thinks
that they
can definitely prove this case beyond a
reasonable doubt however
he said that the laws in the state of
florida have changed regarding the death
penalty things have gotten tougher and
he said
only once in the last 20 years has a
jury in palm beach county been willing
to
sentence or recommend a sentence of
death for
a defendant in a murder trial so they
just decided to forgo it and just
present the case and go for
just a conviction on murder whatever
that penalty may be
it looks like the prosecution is
deciding that the landscape in that
county would not grant uh death penalty
they're kind of picking their battles it
makes sense
to go for a sure thing rather than
something they may not be able to attain
thank you all for contributing coming up
on law and crime daily the appeals court
decision
for the making of murder defendant
steven avery plus
the secret witness in the robert durst
trial revealed find out what the
defendant's friend
said about the relay state error charged
in the murder of his best friend
next
[Music]
welcome back let's check in on the day's
top legal stories
including a jury finding democratic
donor ed buck
guilty in the overdose deaths of two men
he offered drugs
for sex ed buck was convicted of nine
felony counts in federal court on
tuesday
prosecutors say buck lured two black men
back to his apartment
to consume drugs in exchange for sex
acts in a practice described as party
and play gamel moore and timothy dean
died of methamphetamine overdoses at
buck's home in 2017
and 2019. he now faces up to life in
prison and separate charges in los
angeles district court
in wisconsin the court of appeals is
denying a claim by convicted murderer
stephen avery he's serving a life
sentence for the murder of teresa
halbach
on halloween 2005. after abra's case
gained attention from the netflix series
making a murderer a lawyer filed an
appeal claiming she had new evidence
that would exonerate him
but in a unanimous opinion the wisconsin
court of appeals ruled
avery's claims were insufficient and the
trial court didn't air
in not granting a hearing avery's lawyer
kathleen zellner tweeted
not deterred by the appellate court
decision it pointed out the specific
doors that are still open for mr avery's
quest for freedom
avery's nephew brendan daisy is also
serving a life sentence for hull buck's
murder
and in california prosecutors appear to
be wrapping up their case against real
estate heir robert durst
durst is on trial for the murder of his
best friend susan berman
in december 2000. in court prosecutors
played the recorded testimony of the
defendant's longtime friend
nick shaven shaven testified in 2017
that durst admitted to killing his wife
kathy
in 1982. prosecutors alleged durst
killed berman because she threatened to
go forward with information
about durst's involvement in kathy's
death durst has pled
not guilty the u.s government has sold
the one-of-a-kind wu-tang clang album
once owned by farmer bro martin shirelli
the department of justice didn't say how
much the once upon a time in shaolin
album
was bought for but records show shkreli
paid more than two million dollars for
it in 2015.
the sale will go towards satisfying a
7.4 million dollar forfeiture
shkreli was ordered to pay up the former
hedge fund manager was convicted of
engaging
in security fraud schemes he's currently
in prison serving a seven year sentence
now to a story that's a bit stinkier
police in indiana are urging a serial
pooper to seek professional assistance
immediately
officers and fishers say a woman has
been defecating in yards on her daily
runs
the unnamed plopper even apparently
brought toilet paper with her that
discarded evidence
neighbors would later fight the
dastardly deed led locals to putting up
these
signs designating no pooping zones the
fishers police department says she won't
face criminal charges
for now but are encouraging her to seek
medical aid
when we come back the emotional victim
impact statements
as a father confronts his daughter's
convicted killer and the defendant's
mother
fighting back with the judge next
welcome back a south carolina man was
sentenced to spend the rest of his life
in prison
for murdering a college student who got
into his car thinking it was her uber
ride
a jury convicted nathaniel rowland for
kidnapping and murdering
21-year-old samantha josephson video
from outside a bar in colombia on march
29
2019 shows josephson getting into the
back seat of roland's chevy impala
cell phone records from the defendant
shows his phone traveling near the bar
and where her body was found hours later
investigators say she fought back
stabbed more than 120 times an image her
parents say
they can't get out of their minds
i have visions of her foot on the back
window
i have visions of her screaming
and fighting i have visions
of her taking her last breath
i have such hatred running through me
i still to this day can't believe she is
gone
i keep waiting for her to walk through
the door
saying hey only the way she does
the defendant's mother spoke on his
behalf but her refusal to accept her
son's guilt
only seemed to upset the judge
the state has accused our son of a crime
that he had
didn't commit i'm not going to hear him
all right any claim of innocence
he's been convicted by the jury okay
i know my son didn't do this
i know how do you know sir
how do you know by the way by the way i
raised them
and when you're a mother
and you're a truly good mother
and you raise your child in the right
way
you would know when that child had done
something i did something
right or wrong i can't
i can't and i know
he didn't do this
what he did or didn't do he is guilty of
murder he's guilty of
of kidnapping he's guilty of possession
of a weapon
during the commission of a violent crime
then the defendant gave a brief
statement before being sentenced to life
in prison
i just wish the state would have
would have done more in finding out who
the actual person was
instead of being satisfied with
with detaining me and improving
my guilt as higher standard as a law
requires all points your guilt
and i am absolutely satisfied
i can uncertainly understand the family
being
in total disbelief
that the child that they raised could do
such a
heinous thing could commit such a murder
i have dealt with the heartless
and you fall into that category a person
without
any remorse whatsoever
gigi a lot was said after the verdict
your reaction to the defendant and his
mother's statements in court
you know a lot of times these verdicts
and sentencings they're
more shocking to the families involved
in the situation than the actual
defendant
i'm not surprised by the mother's plea
to the judge here you know i'm sure
she's
especially shocked to hear not only the
verdict but to also make a statement in
defense of her son
asking for leniency in his sentencing
here in
in this case it's obvious that neither
statements had any effect on the judge's
ruling
and i do have to remark how
compassionate this judge was in the
rendering of the sentencing here
absolutely now terry speaking of the
judge you've been a big fan of his
uh since almost day one how did he
handle the sentencing
of the murder that sparked the rideshare
safety movement you're right brian i am
a huge fan of this judge i think he
handled the sentence
perfectly he gave maximum and he
explained
why he said that this individual had a
depraved
heart he explained and this was good for
the family of the victim
that samantha put up an amazing fight
and she left sufficient evidence
for the jury to come back with the
correct verdict and i think that was
very helpful
he also said that in all of his 40 years
brian
that law enforcement did the best job he
had ever seen
so he's talking about the case that the
prosecution put on in the fact
that they put on an excellent case and
at the end
he said this is not a very difficult
sentencing it's a very
easy sentencing and that's exactly why
he sentenced this this individual
to the maximum sentence now terry we see
this and i think i ask this question
after
every trial when we get a verdict in a
sentence we know the defense is going to
make an appeal it's his right to do so
do you see any appellate issues any
errors by the judge or anyone
that may grant this defendant a new
trial
you know brian i've said this before and
i'll say it again
when you have a judge like this who
carefully considers all of the evidence
there were no war dear issues nothing
was left out
nothing was put in that shouldn't have
been i don't think there's
any ground here for any sort of appeal
or new trial
i think this was a tight case and i
think the conviction will hold and so
will the sentencing
all right gigi terry as always thank you
for contributing
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america here
the law and crime daily
always a pleasure to have you have a
good night
[Music]
you